was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jedes gut ich nehme das
mikrofon ein bisschen näher dran weil
ich habe oft lesen in den kommentaren
dass es schlechter sound es halt wie
gesagt ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich
muss mich entschuldigen wir uns jetzt
eine ganze woche nicht gesehen hast du
mir sehr leid eigentlich war für letzte
woche noch ein cooles video angedacht
ist noch nicht da kann man nichts machen
heute ist aber mal wieder ein echtes
paket gekommen und zwar weiß ich viele
von euch feiern jetzt hier die mistel
boxen ich habe bei saturn bestellt apple
mystery boxen real mystery boxen und
jetzt haben wir halt eine von ebay dies
von einem privaten händler der hat mir
ich kann euch das eigene mahlzeiten im
moment wie hier die nachricht in
kurzfassung er hat auf jeden fall die
mistel blogs videos gesehen testet und
beurteilt für verschiedene anbieter oft
produkte und hat daher einen berg von
elektronik und lifestyleprodukten die ja
nicht selber alle benutzen kann anstatt
die alle einzeln zu verkaufen machte
lieber boxen daraus so müsst ihr die
boxen und ich habe mir das angucken das
echt sehr nice und jetzt ist was
angekommen ich zeige euch mal
das ist die box ich muss sagen die ist
ungefähr so schwer wie die erste saturn
box die wir hatten für 200 euro also
jetzt schon glaube ich eine menge drin
ich muss mal kurz meine adresse hier
schmerzen so sieht das von vorne aus der
hat was drauf geschrieben facebook.com
amazon gadgets ich konnte mir das
eigentlich mal kurz an ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob ich auf der richtigen seite
würde auf jeden fall gibt es ganz viele
amazonen angebote mir fällt auf das
paket ist halt auch in einem amazon
karton die aber dann auch noch mal eine
einbindung von den ebay angebot was ich
da bestellt habe ich meine das hätte 150
euro mit ca jetzt habe ich genug
gelagert ich bin ultra gespannt wir
machen das mal auf ihr selbst hinter der
kamera das sieht man gar nicht dass
stehen so viele sachen aus den letzten
mysterien boxen aber auch noch weitere
sachen die ich zugeschickt bekommen habe
alles zu verlosen wir alles im dezember
rausgehauen
und wenn hier jetzt was cooles drin ist
das natürlich auch deswegen lohnt es
sich sehr zu abonnieren okay ich bin
gespannt als das macht es sind auch
einfach meine lieblingsvideos das macht
so viel spaß okay es ist wirklich eine
menge drin
hier haben war moment so wer von euch
möchte einmal vorlesen bitte ach so ich
soll es machen ok hallo überraschungs
freund herzlichen glückwunsch zu meiner
surprise box diese box enthält zufällig
zusammen gepackt waren aus den bereichen
elektronik und lifestyle spiel spaß
spannung und schokolade das war der
slogan von kinder überraschungseiern
erinnerst du dich es ist schlimm wenn
ich mich nicht daran erinnern ich habe
aber auch nie so viele kinder
überraschungseier gegessen gespannt bist
du bestimmt schon fürs spiel ist auch
etwas in der box nur nicht so viel
schokolade jetzt aber viel spaß beim
aufkochen dann wollen wir doch mal ein
handy wäre auf jeden fall wieder sehr
nein als erstes habe ich hier die triple
eco friendly what a bottle ok eine
wasserflasche
ist ganz heiß kann man immer gebrauchen
wobei ich habe ziemlich viele
wasserflaschen aber die kommt dann halt
einfach mal dazu heißt nichts ist haben
wir hier
ich stelle die box immer zur seite das
hier ist
es sieht aus wie eine tablet tasche oder
halt auch für kleinere notebooks genau
hier kannst du deinen tablet reinstecken
oder einen kleinen laptop qualität ist
ganz gut auch dann danke dafür kann ich
selber nicht gebrochen weil mein macbook
zum beispiel das viel zu groß dort wird
er nicht reinpassen ich habe ein tablet
aber ist jetzt passt es müsste passen
egal wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt ich hoffe es wird immer besser
also da ist wirklich viel drin muss ich
sagen socken gut das muss ich jetzt
nicht extra auspacken das sind socken
mit hasen muster oder so kein plan hier
haben wir auf jeden fall was für die
ladies professional
vorher tipps made in china ach so ja das
erinnert mich bis jetzt erinnert mich
das ein bisschen an diese an die videos
von mir in denen ich amazon produkte
ausgepackt habe die ich nie bestellt
habe das war auch alles made in china
und irgendwie so lager auflösung oder
sowas das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
kampf den kann man erhitzen und dann
kann man damit seine haare glätten
kennen ich habe keine ahnung kenne ich
mich nicht aus werde ich auch nie
benutzten deswegen durch das auf jeden
fall auch zu den sachen die im dezember
rausgehauen werden das
studium das hat gerade ewig gedauert bis
ich dieses ding wieder hier drin hatte
und das macht einen immer ein bisschen
aggressiv am anfang stehen oder auf
jeden fall das ist jetzt sich das meiste
aber besser als nix und trotzdem glaube
ich dass viele mills damit was anfangen
können deswegen ja irgendwie freut sich
bestimmt das jetzt bin ich noch nicht so
ganz überzeugt aber das kann sich ja
noch ändern weil wir haben noch eine
menge nach einfach mal hier mit weiter
das lag ganz oben drauf es ist auch
wieder made in china ich muss sagen ich
verbinde damit ich unbedingt
positive gefühle
also ist sieht ein bisschen aus wie leds
oder so company nation dongfang magi
optoelectronics geschichten aus johnson
ich stecke das einfach mal anderen
werden wir ja sehen was passiert
also es sind auf jeden fall so led
stripes wenn ich jetzt mal man kann die
farbe ändern und die halt irgendwo dran
kleben aber warum hier soviel kabel
dabei ist
naja also wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen
könnte ich sehr gern mal kommentieren
aber ich habe so was noch nie gesehen
kommt ja auch noch schön sein netz wie
hochwertig die
verpackung sie zu hause als wäre das von
apple oder wenn man das jetzt nur so
sieht aber nein es ist von der
weltbekannten merkel blazer ein solar
ladegerät
ich glaube ich kenne ja das habe ich
schon mal bei uns bestellt also es
funktioniert hat wie eine power bank man
kann sein handy daran stecken und wenn
die sonne scheint nimmt das ding halt
auch ganz minimal solar strahlen auf
wandelt die energie und theoretisch
kannst du dann damit ein bisschen dein
handy laden bei mir das nicht so ganz
gut funktioniert aber vielleicht ist
dieses gerät ja besser sechs mal zur
seite und märz bei gelegenheit mal
testen ansonsten dann auch einfach
irgendwie anderen zuschauer verlosen wir
werden sehen ich gehe jetzt mal ein
kleines hinzu weil wir haben hier echt
auf die drin diese ganze folie kommt
raus hier haben wir die porti ihn okay
alles klar whey protein noch mehr weil
ihn noch mehr whey protein das hier ist
ein herz von der aok wollte ich schon
immer mal haben danke dafür hier haben
wir noch mehr protein und natürlich noch
ein bisschen mehr protein und hier
irgendwo habe ich gerade noch mehr
protein gelesen gutschein was ist das
sind fit nur ein gutschein für fit and
move in sankt augustin
ich glaube da fahre ich dann extra mal
hin und macht einen kurs mit einem monat
fitnesstraining irgendwer von euch geht
doch bestimmt in diesem fitnessstudio
trainieren oder fitten gemeinsam
effizient bewegen schreibt wir gerne mal
vielleicht könnt ihr damit etwas
anfangen dann haben wir als nächstes
hier nochmal eine
powermat ist einfach eine power bringt
ziemlich klein und kompakt das finde ich
immer sehr gut wobei ich auch ganz
ehrlich sagen muss ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben eine eigene power bank
gehabt nicht so mitgenommen haben und
immer aufgeladen habe ich weiß nicht
irgendwo findet man auch immer einen
stecker okay noch mehr leds ja das sind
diese dinger die man kennt kann man
unten um sein bett wickel oder irgendwo
an die wand oder hinter dem fernseher
keine ahnung dass es immerhin fünf meter
langen doch das papier noch mehr papier
also es ist wirklich schon viel drin das
muss ich sagen und ich glaube wir haben
hier noch ein handy auszupacken das
sieht auf jeden fall von der verwaltung
her so aus bis jetzt die sachen waren
alle nicht schlecht es war nichts dabei
was mich komplett umgehauen hat aber das
kann man bei 150 euro oder 145 euro
glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt erwarten
weiter geht's hier mit hier haben wir
einen usb typ ca das ist so ein adapter
alles klar weiß ich wie es aussieht das
jetzt nicht interessant dann haben wir
hier noch
desinfektionsmittel oder so was
ähnliches
wir sind ja also das ist wirklich so ein
phänomen ich habe so oft in
irgendwelchen paketen so sex sachen wir
haben wir jetzt kleid gilt für anal spaß
und das stelle ich mir mal zur seite
vielleicht kann man sie irgendwann mal
verbinden was ist das denn
wieder natürlich made entscheiden foster
korrektor also wenn man seinen rücken
irgendwie bisschen schief hat hilft das
kann man umschlagen und dann ist das
wahrscheinlich gesünder für den rücken
denk ich mal aber ich muss sagen
mein rücken ist noch halbwegs okay
deswegen brauche ich das noch nicht die
haben wir noch einen schlüsselanhänger
und jetzt leute jetzt wird es
interessant als erstes habe ich hier
schon mal eine ring leuchte das ist ganz
wichtig für das influenza als starter
pack wenn ihr influenza werden möchte
braucht ihr diese ring leuchtet schon
vor die qualität von den dingen an weil
ich muss sagen ring durch gekündigt
theoretisch aufgebraucht
hier noch ein stativ sei fast so leute
das ist fürs handy hier kann man jetzt
sein handy zwischen klemmen wir machen
mal kurz an dann kann ich sagen also bis
jetzt substanz sei also so sieht das
denn aus die ist jetzt nicht mega hält
aber sollte reichen von anfang ich habe
auf jeden fall genug professionelle
beleuchtung das heißt wenn jemand von
euch vor allem die mädels die nächste
dgb werden möchte dann kommentiert das
doch mal okay und jetzt kommen wir dann
zu den smartphones welche sind keine
also wir haben hier zwei päckchen da
könnten schon handys sohn sein oder
machen wir das mal auf bedeuten
durchstarten ene mene miste ich starte
mit dem schwarzen wobei ich muss auch
irgendwie sagen das ist ein bisschen zu
leicht für handy
ach so ihr könnt ja gar nichts mehr
sehen so sieht gut aus das ist das ach
so das ist eine kamera
bekam eine mini wlan kamera mit
nachsicht funktion das heißt sie kann
man irgendwo hinstellen mit seinem handy
verbindung dann kannst du sehen ist das
stalking kamera die knallig maria ist
irgendwo in ihr zimmer aber sagt er das
nicht dann kann ich sie immer beobachten
okay hier ist jetzt ein handy drin ich
habe jetzt gerade schon gesehen hier
haben wir erstmal ein usb stick kann
aber auch noch eine ist das nicht eine
musikbox oder das ist eine musikbox
ebenfalls aus shenzen eigentlich könnte
man auch sagen mystery box direkt aus
shenzen von der qualität her würde ich
mal sagen ganz okay dann haben wir jetzt
hier noch die letzten beiden sachen das
wäre einmal das ist das sind ach so das
ist ein adapter für die steckdose den
kann man das ist ganz gut wenn man
irgendwie in amerika ist oder in england
da gibt es ja immer verschiedene
steckdosen kann man den glaube ich ganz
gut gebrauchen den werde ich auf jeden
fall behalten und zu guter letzt haben
wir hier noch eine prostate
na wer hätte das gedacht
das ist auf jeden fall das was ich mir
schon gedacht hab ich kann sicher nicht
zeigen sonst wird das video hier wieder
wäre unfreundlich das wollen wir ja
nicht bevor ich es vergesse was für ein
gesamtwert die ganzen produkte haben ist
halt ein bisschen schwierig zu bestimmen
weil ich meine die sind alle made in
china kosten wahrscheinlich jetzt neu
wenn man sie auf amazon bestellt über 5
600 euro halt alle zusammen ich will das
jetzt aber nicht so sagen weil ich
glaube dass sind auch viele sachen die
halt kein abnehmer finden und die nicht
so gefragt sind also ich muss sagen im
großen und ganzen
viele produkte drin viele sachen aus
china aber es hat trotzdem mal wieder
ultra viel spaß gemacht das alles
auszupacken gerne wieder wenn ihr noch
irgendwelche boxen habe ich unbedingt
mal bestellen soll schreibt das in die
kommentare wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich
am freitag wieder da gibt es nämlich ein
video ich habe zehn restposten laptops
aus polen bestellt also wirklich laptops
die ich dann vielleicht auch
weiterverkaufen werden dass wir so ein
etwas größeres projekt ich bin euch hier
mal eben ein foto ein von der geschenke
wie sieht nämlich ultraleicht aus und
abonniert super gehen den kanal und wir
sehen uns dann die woche wieder haut
rein danke fürs zuschauen chart